[Musique]
telle est la principale menace à
l'échelle mondiale
le venezuela possède les plus grandes
réserves de pétrole de la planète
alors pourquoi ce pays traverse l'une
des pires crises humanitaires de
l'histoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc vous pensez que les rues se vendent
leur destine mans des armes au venezuela
ce serait logique
d'après son nom par save a causé la
panique en cas d'attaqué nucléaire du
venezuela vous ne lirez pas dans la
presse parce qu'on sera tous morts
[Musique]
loisirs ou affaire jack affaire
qu'est ce qui s'est passé reyes
regardez-moi son nom at il été mentionné
si vous restez vous ne serez pas
protéger personne viendra vous sauver
si on le fait on le faire ensemble c'est
pas un problème